- How was your dad?
What made him a great dad?
'Cause he had to of
been really busy, right?
- You know what,
he was very present.
And, he figured out,
my parents, together, figured out,
given their life situation,
how to be present.
And it looks different
for every single family.
Everyone has a lot of plates
that they're spinning,
and it's different for every individual.
And so, what that looked like,
in terms of my childhood
was we were just traveling.
My mom would figure it
out so that all four kids,
we could go wherever my dad was going.
And we would enroll in local schools,
or get homeschooled, and--
- Wow, it's almost like touring musicians.
It's almost like how,
'cause a lot of musicians
bring their kids on the road,
and families on the road.
- Yes, that's exactly, exactly it,
and it was awesome, because I loved it.
And my parents figured out pretty early,
that they could really control me
by threatening that I wouldn't
be allowed to go to
set if I didn't behave.
(laughing)
- I'm not above bribery
or threatening, myself.
No, I think that's cool.
- And so, that happened, yeah.
- Yeah.
Well, I have a little surprise for you.
- Oh, do you?
- I have a Father's Day surprise for you.
- [Bryce] Of Father's Day?
- Yes, a video was sent
to us just for you.
Here, here we go.
We're gonna play it.
- Hey, Kelly, well let's see,
an embarrassing story about Bryce.
Well, she was a great kid,
and she loved visiting the set,
and she was very, very helpful.
In fact, by the time she was 11 or 12,
she was actually pitching in
as a production assistant.
In fact, she was so efficient
that she was finally
given the responsibility
of having a walkie-talkie,
so that the production assistants
could talk to one another
and give direction and guidance,
and I mean that was a
real honor and a show
of appreciation for how
much or who she was.
It was great.
The first day, she was
terrific, she was on it.
The second day was good too,
except suddenly over the walkie-talkie,
we heard Bryce ordering
the extras holding area
to be moved from one side of
a building over to the other.
Now, granted she was trying
to get it out of the sun
and into the shade,
and her thinking was pretty good,
but it's not quite cool
to have the 12-year-old
taking over the production.
So she lost her walkie-talkie that day,
but I knew that one day,
she'd wanna be behind the
scenes calling the shots,
and she does it really well.